and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn Ryan Nicodemus is
actually down in Florida taking care of
his grandma right now but that's okay we
ever meet safety in the building in the
studio how you doing outstanding how are
you I'm doing great thank you for being
here today
thanks for having me so so we're gonna
talk about some stuff today you have a
book it's 10 years old now
congratulations and second edition is
out it's called I will teach you how to
be rich I will teach you to be rich oh
there's no how in there that's important
because here's the thing actually that's
perfect
because I accidentally inserted some
words into this title in fact I was a
bit turned off by the title of the book
years ago because I realized I was
placed on my own judgments on it because
it was we think of rich what do we think
about we think of filthy rich I will
teach you how to be filthy rich as
opposed to I will teach you how to be
rich or I will teach you to be rich I
found myself inserting some words there
now what was the impetus of of writing
this book and we're gonna dive in some
questions here in a moment but can you
talk about why you wrote this a decade
ago and why was it time to revise it at
this point the reason that I wrote the
book was I had been writing a blog for
years I started it when I was in college
and the reason that I started the blog
was that I tried to teach my friends
about money in college
and nobody came nobody wants to go to an
event about money it makes him feel bad
about themselves and so I started
writing a blog and I wanted to write a
blog as if you and I were sitting here
just like we are and we'd be talking
about the cheap friend we've got who
doesn't never tips and what do I do with
two thousand bucks I've got sitting in
my checking account and what are all
these investing things people talk about
I started writing it making it fun I
started learning and after I had done
that for several years I treated my blog
like a lab an experimental laboratory so
I was studying human behavior in
psychology and all the money advice out
there is very academic keep a budget
don't spend money on lattes
it all sounds nice on a piece of paper
until you actually tried in real life
and I didn't want to live a life where I
was counting pennies for the rest of my
life so I started this blog started
treated like an experimental lab and
after several years I built a system I
loved systems that's scaled what that
meant is I could spend less than an hour
a month on my money it was going where I
needed it to go and at that point people
kept asking me the same questions like
the same 20 questions okay what do I do
with my money what's the best savings
account blah blah blah tell you the
truth the reason I wrote the book was I
just wanted to hand it to him and be
like read this like you're the answers
to your five questions and the 15 you
should be asking read the book guys you
know now with with this book to be rich
means something different last night we
went to a book launch event that you had
in West Hollywood and we sort of did
this roundtable where you asked everyone
like what is their rich life and it's
fascinating because quite often when we
think of rich it's what I just said is
like what is filthy rich and you think
of opulence you think of unnecessary
splurging on things that probably aren't
going to add value to our lives and what
I really liked is you went around and
asked people what their rich life was
and some people were like it means I can
go out to dinner once a week or it means
that I'm able to put my kids into a
private school or whatever it might be
and everyone has a different idea of
what a rich life is yeah I think you're
a hundred percent right that the tight
look I don't know if I'd name this book
I will teach you to be rich again I
picked it when I was in college and I
was sober when I picked a name but it
was a punchy title and let's be honest
if you take a look at a book called I
will teach you to be rich with this huge
text on the front I'm not surprised that
a few years ago you said s not for me
because I didn't like to me rich was
almost a turn-off because I walked away
from a corporate world personally where
I was making good money I was Austin
still be rich although I was broke man I
made really good money I was making a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
in Dayton Ohio and I met I was living
paycheck to paycheck I wasn't actually
rich I was irresponsible with the funds
I was making
by the way I wasn't spinning on things
that brought me greater joy happiness I
certainly didn't feel like I was living
a rich life completely understand and
and so what happens is you start doing
maybe you're doing well maybe you're in
debt it doesn't matter what your
financial situation is a rich life is
correlated although not identical to how
much money you've got I was rich before
I had money I grew up with two parents
in America I went to a great college and
I made great friends I was rich back
then
then I added money to it now money we
should be really clear money is an
important part of a rich life but it's a
small part it's it's in many ways an
amplifier I think it's an amplifier I
think so I think there's this phrase
there's so many phrases in our culture
that reveal ourselves and one of them is
money changes people and listen to how
people say that money changes people
such a disparaging tone you know what of
course money changes people it should
change people it should make you be able
to dream bigger than you ever thought it
should make you be able to take
something that you didn't enjoy doing or
doesn't add value and remove it from
your life or delegate it from your life
or simply make it go away
money should change your life but the
common perception is that if I made a
million dollars I'm gonna start blowing
it on this and that and that doesn't
have to happen that reveals a profound
lack of trust in yourself I know I
always knew and I know it now if I made
10 times more than what I make today
it's not like I'm gonna go blow it on a
bunch of Ferraris that I don't care
about I bought a four-door Honda Accord
when I graduated from college like I'm a
sensible Indian dude but I know that I
knew that if I made more money I would
be able to dial into the things that
value that I value things like
relationships for example I brought my
wife and I brought our parents along
with us on our six-week honeymoon we
could talk about that yeah at for part
of it not for all of it for the first
week and then we're like have a nice
time and also you've updated the book to
talk about relationship advice with
respect to money
totally and that is another area where
as you accumulate money which again is
just a small but important part of a
rich life you can
use it to craft your rich life with your
partner or with your parents or with
your friends my dream when I started off
was just to be able to order rounded
drinks for my friends and not have to
worry do I have enough money in the bank
that's a rich life and then as you make
more money your dreams can get bigger so
yes money does change people but it
should and you choose where where and
how it changes you it is an amplifier
when I say amplifier I mean it can
amplify your bad behaviors true and/or
it can amplify your good behaviors right
we often talk about tools and technology
is one of those tools but a fairly crude
analogy is like if you have a chainsaw
you can use it for all kinds of really
good things like oh my god this trees
about to fall on my neighbor's house let
me protect them by by cutting the limbs
off or whatever or you can use it to
chop your neighbor in the tiny little
pieces it really depends on on how you
use that tool and money is a tool I also
think that we we we unfortunately treat
it as if it is the most important thing
in our lives and then of course we want
to swing away from that and we pretend
it's not important at all hundred
percent we have a very paradoxical
culture which is extremely unhealthy on
one hand it's so puritanical people are
using words like money changes people or
money's evil to the root of all evil
that's not even the real quote but
that's what people repeat and if if they
made money they had to step on people to
get there all these phrases that we grew
up with but on in last night you were
you actually had people so when you
think of money what is the first thing
you talk about I heard words like
anxiety or debt embarrassed and bare
struggle yeah and then a few people were
like security or flexibility oh yeah we
had a couple yesterday that used my book
and my material and there were a couple
and they said we love that we can decide
hey we want to go to Paris next week
let's go that is a rich life to them and
that's flexibility so it's so
interesting that in our culture we talk
about all the negative things about
money but nobody sits down and actually
talks about the real positive ones
notice by the way that the minute you
start talking about the positive people
will immediately drift into the negative
they'll go like this you go
what good money do for you what's your
rich life
and people will say oh I could travel
it's not like I need to go first-class
everywhere it's not like I need this or
that they start by saying what they
don't want
we love to define ourselves by what we
don't do and what I would challenge
people with a rich life is to define
yourself by what you do what you want
and then work backwards from there isn't
it fascinating how one person's rich
life is another person sort of misery
right yeah I know for me I really
dislike travelling and and so I think
about these people were like yeah if I
just had a million dollars I could
travel the world I'm like if I had a
million dollars the last thing I would
want to do is travel the world with that
and that was what was so fascinating
about the event last night is people it
wasn't this that you put specificity
behind what a rich like this let me ask
you this what is your rich life my rich
life is to be able to never have to make
a bad decision because of money
specifically never have to work with
someone that I don't like or that I
don't respect if that's the case goodbye
like they don't work with me anymore and
that could be an employee a vendor
person place I get coffee from that's it
it's to be able to travel for one month
per year with my wife and it's to be
able to create a family trip with my
whole family at least once every couple
of years where we just kind of really
enjoy bring the nephews and nieces with
us so those are the things that are my
rich life but I have to tell you that
Epson flows over time okay well like
when I started out 22 years old it was
to be able to order appetizers because I
never got to do that growing up as a kid
then it was like oh I moved to New York
I want to take the train excuse me I
want to take a cab
during summer cuz I don't want to walk
into a meeting dripping with sweat I
sweat a lot look at this body hair I
sweat a lot and then you know your
dreams get bigger right so then it was
for example with our honeymoon this was
an interesting example that I didn't
even realize how small I was thinking so
my plan when we got married was I've
been saving for a honeymoon for a long
time one of the things I talk about in
the book is the difference between the
wealthy and everyone else is the wealthy
save before they need to so I've been
saving for my wedding when I was in my
mid-20s even though I never met my wife
until I was in my mid
and same for a honeymoon engagement ring
all the stuff that is predictable but
you just don't quite know when it's
gonna happen and I show how to do that
with these automated savings accounts so
we had planned like let's go on a seven
or eight days Safari that was our plan
sounds like an amazing honeymoon I've
never been there and we sat down with a
couple couple of couples and we told
them and they were a bit older and
they'd been married for a while and they
said oh that sounds amazing when we went
on our honeymoon we took six months off
and my wife and soon-to-be wife looked
at each other like who the hell are
these people
and then they a couple necks it was like
we took a year off and we walked out of
that dinner we thought they were just
normal people like you or me but we
walked out looking at each other like
our first reaction which is the common
reaction when you hear someone spending
time or money in a crazy way you say
that's ridiculous but then the second
place we went was this this amazing
place called what if what if we did that
what if we just spent a year abroad and
we didn't want to do a year but we it
kind of blew my mind and it's ironic
because I teach people how to dream
bigger and how to execute bigger whether
it's money
career psychology entrepreneurship and
we started to say what if we did that
and so that we were now living in a
place of imagination so we started
saying six weeks let's make a list of
all the places we could go and we're
really bad at geography so we plotted
them on Google Maps they're like all
over the world like okay okay let's dial
it back six weeks and independently our
dream which we kind of came to on our
own was let's bring our parents with us
so let's bring him to Italy Italy safe
everybody loves cheese right and like we
can take him to the Vatican it'll be
beautiful
so we brought them and what was amazing
was her parents never even had a
passport so it was a big deal we brought
them with us we created these magical
memories that you know we will never be
able to experience that exact thing
again and we loved it and then we went
on to Kenya India and Thailand so that
was our rich life for that moment in
time and we just absolutely loved it
we're gonna dive some more into the book
we do have some questions today that I
want to
- today we're gonna talk about earning
income we'll talk about managing money
we'll talk about financial willpower and
that's something that you talk about
we're gonna talk about some budgeting
mistakes and I think we may even
disagree on budgeting a little bit in
the word budgeting yeah I think I think
we might disagree on that a little bit
we're gonna talk more about what it
means to live a rich life and so let's
dive into some of these questions here
our first question is from Rene in
Oklahoma City so I have 125 dollars a
month today and I would like to have a
recommendation for me wrong on what is
the wisest way to invest or save 125
dollars every month now this word budget
is almost a bad word for you it's like
the worst four-letter word now I I'm a
bit of a disciple of Dave Ramsey we went
out on tour with his his team last
summer so and I agree with probably 99%
of what he talks about then the 1% I
disagree with our opinions by the way I
think were you and I are going to
disagree today if we do are actually
going to be on our own opinions we're
not gonna disagree about facts I don't
think right and there's a fact here the
Renee hat has 125 dollars a month to
save is that effect exactly oh that's a
question right is it a fact because what
I would say is well if you have a budget
maybe you would have more than 125
dollars a month to say so let's talk
about that okay I'll tell you we I love
healthy disagreements so I'm pumped I
love it and I think that for people
listening
it is very revealing because there are
sometimes facts that you know that are
just cut and dry and then a lot of times
there are different ways to look at the
same thing so I don't like budgets for
several reasons number one they don't
work when people you talk to any
American and they know they should keep
a budget and yet they don't and why is
that because number one it makes people
feel bad about themselves and if there's
anything Americans are good at it's
avoiding feeling bad number two they
don't know how much they owe or how much
spend but they know it's bad and so
who's gonna go through the work of
actually riding down this stuff or
opening up some account and then looking
at it they might do it for one month
they may do it for two but after that
it's done and I've seen as consistently
through my own millions and millions of
readers what I prefer is something that
is similar but very different and that
is instead of looking backwards at what
you spent look forward and say where do
I want my money to go and so what I do
in the book is I recommend some specific
percentages here's how much you should
be saving here's how much you should be
investing and this one people really
love here's how much you should be
spending on guilt-free spending you want
to buy a leather jacket you want to go
out to an amazing dinner awesome be my
guest so I want people to not
necessarily look backwards in their
spending but actually look forward and
as part of that focus on the things they
love as part of their rich life that is
much more motivational it also sticks a
lot more than every month looking at
what you spent and feeling bad it sounds
to me like what you're describing is a
budget and so maybe we're just using
different vernacular in a way because I
know an app that is really it's it's
Dave Ramsey's app that every dollar app
which I think sometimes we just don't
know where our money is going right and
I think what you're talking about when
you say looking forward is like okay how
if I'm making 2,000 I'm bringing home
$2,000 a month
how am I going to best spend this money
right and it sounds to me like Renee is
saying okay well have that mm I have
$125 left and now she's asking what well
what the hell do I do with this money I
think they're similar but I don't think
they're exactly the same so if you talk
to someone who keeps a strict budget and
they track where they where they're
spending it I bet you they're really
good at knowing how much they spend on
groceries every month or how much they
spend on their car payment but if you
ask them where do you want your money to
go where do you want to be in a year or
three years what are your values that
are being represented through your
spending they will suddenly get very
quiet because it's one thing to know
line by line how much you're spending on
your car payment in groceries it's an
other thing to say this is my philosophy
this is what I love spending on and I
spend sixteen percent of my money on
this area because I love it but I spend
only three percent of my money or have
no TV because that's not part of my
financial values so that is there is a
subtle but profound difference now I
will say that I do encourage people to
track their spending for a couple of
weeks in the book but beyond that I want
them to look forward not only look
backwards yes
so with Rene she says she has 125 bucks
left first thing I would say is if
you're in debt I would I would get out
of debt and I'd use that money to pay
off debt that be my personal advice what
I would do if I were in her scenario now
if Rene is indeed debt free where do we
go from there well there's a short
answer and there's a longer answer the
short answer is I would start saving
that money and build up about three
months of expenses that's a nice
emergency fund once she's got that built
up which will take her a while she can
then go on and start investing it and
there are nice ways to do that simple
easy ways like a target date fund what I
would the longer answer is I would say
are you sure you have a hundred and
twenty-five dollars only I would love to
take a look at her spending I would love
to take a look at her income there are
often ways to save hundreds thousands of
dollars like right off the bat and I'll
tell you some of the stuff in the book
and I have the exact words that you can
use people pay their cable companies and
they don't realize you can call them and
negotiate six hundred dollars off with
one phone call same with your cell phone
company same sometimes often with your
rent okay I've done that before in
Manhattan so there's lots of different
ways you can make instant savings and
that money can automatically go into a
savings account or in her case an
investment account as well and so you
can reduce those expenses you can
radically reduce them by eliminating and
like you said it yeah I'm paying you
know 60 bucks a month for cable but I
watch it three times a month why am I
even paying for this at all and so
instantly you've given yourself a raise
yeah one of the things that Ryan and I
often say is that the best way to give
yourself a pay raise is to spend less
money like that's an immediate pay raise
but then also in the book you do talk
about like it's not just about saving
money it's about bringing more money in
or finding different ways to to increase
your income there is a limit to how much
you can cut rare is no limit to how much
you can
earng yeah if you're spending $20,000 a
year right now you can only cut $20,000
a year yeah and at a certain point
you've you've cut to the bone what's
interesting is I'll just say this one
thing about cutting when people come to
me and they say I've cut to the bone
there's nothing else I can do I say okay
what have you done and they basically
say I've done one thing and that's it
and so there's usually more than people
think they can do but there is a limit
and I find it much more rewarding and
also more mathematically compelling to
focus on the earning side now there's a
very interesting question about why
don't more personal finance people talk
about earning more the answer is very
simple they don't know how most people
writing about personal finance their
bread and butter is simply cutting back
and so I wanted to change that with I
will teach you to be rich that's why we
talk about entrepreneurship we talk
about freelancing we talk about the fact
that you can actually doesn't matter
where you live she lives wherever she
lives you can find clients whether
they're local or whether they're remote
and we have people we have caricature
artists we have dog walkers we have
Excel consultants and you can
dramatically increase your earnings last
night one of the guys who was at the
event he said I used your YouTube video
on salary negotiation I sent an email
and I got a $5,000 raise right there are
the actual words and get them for free
on YouTube or on my website or in the
book and you can negotiate massive
raises so people shouldn't forget I have
this thing I call the CEO strategy cut
costs yes
earn more don't forget about that and
then optimize your expenses your cable
your cell phone you can call them up and
you can negotiate five 600 bucks off
right away I like what you said about
values a moment ago because I don't want
money to be the primary driver for doing
what you do if you're making money just
for the sake of making money that's not
it's not very fun in long term it's it's
not it's not a rewarding strategy I mean
you might reward your bank account but
you we've all seen you know the the the
the sort of picture of opulence like the
the the guy alone in his mansion sort of
thing and like
I don't aspire to be that what you're
talking about is identifying what your
values are and then figuring out how
money will amplify those values 100% and
I agree with you I mean in fact when I
was in my early 20s if you had asked me
what do you think about money I would
have said I want more and if you had
said why I wouldn't have had a good
answer I might have just said some words
but ultimately it was something that I
wanted I want and I was willing to work
for it which is good but there wasn't
much thought as to why and so I think
it's an interesting journey because I
came from a family that was very
middle-class my mom stayed home with us
my dad worked
now having earned more through my
business and through investing I can say
that money is important it definitely
allows me to do things and dream bigger
than I ever would have but an extra zero
doesn't change anything
it really doesn't and in also just like
if if I had another million dollars
tomorrow I would not go out and buy a
Ferrari or any kind of cuz I just don't
care about that I don't even have a TV
it's not important my laptop that I run
my entire business off of with dozens of
employees is a 2012 MacBook Air and my
wife makes fun of me but it doesn't
matter it works I like to buy the best
and keep it for as long as I can so I
believe in that but on the other hand I
do have things that I absolutely love
and I spend extravagantly and
unapologetically on those are the things
that get me excited it's not the money
in the bank account it's living outside
the spreadsheet and and you know for
example being able to do this and come
in here but it's not it's not to impress
other people no it's in line with the
person that you want to be in fact if
anything like I'll give you an example
cuz one of my money dials the thing that
I call it a money dial I love spending
on his clothes you will never sell your
wife's a personal stylist she's a
personal stylist and but I loved it
before her but I got a lot more
sophisticated once she taught me what
she does and you will never see me
wearing some big logo shirt in fact if I
am successful my clothes are for me not
for anyone else and you
never know what brand I'm wearing never
so as I became more interested in this
area of life it's funny because most of
my readers they follow me when it comes
to psychology careers etc but they think
clothes are stupid and shallow it's
really funny and so I get it because
when I was younger I thought the same
but then I started to fall in love with
the craft the craft of like who's making
this what's the artisan that's creating
this sweater by hand and as part of our
honeymoon in Italy we went to the
factory of my favorite brand and saw the
artisans creating it and kind of learned
about where they come they have a school
there on the property that to me
represents what when you truly love
something like if somebody has five BMWs
to me I don't get it but to them they're
like let me show you the torque in this
BMW let me show you that I went to
Germany to pick up my car and drive it
on their track they love beyond showing
off at a certain point it's not about
showing off it's about finding the value
in that thing for yourself it's finding
the experience that that resonates with
you because I'm with you like for me
having five BMWs but do know my Toyota
is fine for me yeah although I did used
to Lexus's at one point back in my
corporate days yeah same time and a Land
Rover and there was nothing wrong with
those cars they're really nice cars and
I worked really well but I didn't
actually own them either I was making
the car payment on them every month and
that's a terrible strategy I would never
recommend ever having a car payment I
don't know if you talked about that at
all in the book but listen I have my own
rules on money and one of the things
that I would encourage people to do is
to create their own rules so you can
find mine online it's on my Instagram
account or everywhere one of them is you
know I want to save twenty to thirty
percent every year and if I'm doing that
then I know that my expenses are
basically being handled another one is
that I want to pay I want to pay in full
for large purchases a car I want to be
able to pay in full or go in there and
painful a trip a honeymoon a wedding I
have the money already saved up I am
definitely not going into debt then
there are a couple of others that
surprise people one of them was Mary the
person mm-hmm I think that's probably
the most important financial decision
you can ever make but remember as I say
money is about living outside the
spreadsheet so yes you can learn how to
automate and invest in all this asset
allocation yes you should learn the
technical stuff most people who complain
about money have never spent one weekend
reading anything about money they're 45
Oh boohoo life is so tough Oh systemic
inequality all those things are true but
you never spent 48 hours reading
anything about the most important
complaint in your life get real so
that's that's one thing your
relationship is critical and then
another thing is I wrote a rule saying
any flights over four and a half hours
business class now you might not agree
you might not care you might think it's
a waste of money or you might not be
able to afford it any of those things
are fine what I want everyone to do is
to create their own point of view
I guarantee someone's gonna say you know
go to this steak place once a month
because it's so cool like I don't care
about that steak that's not my thing but
if you love it and you can afford it
god bless that's what I want everyone to
do come up with your own point of view
and be unapologetic about it let's do a
few of these lightning round questions
so we pick up some questions from
Twitter Instagram and Facebook we're at
the minimalists on all those platforms
you're at ramita and Instagram and
Instagram nice and so you can you can
follow him there you can ask him some
more questions on social media our first
question here all by the way we share
these in the show notes as well so what
we do is we try to answer with like a
pithy tweetable answer but really we can
ramble on a little bit and Shawn will
tweeze out something that sounds good
and then Jessica puts all these in one
place minimal maxims calm our first
question is from Nile Chronicles in
Istanbul how can we block the sudden
urge to spend our hard-earned savings on
shopping gifts luxury items and dining
out I mean what can we do to stop the
urge don't block your desires you plan
for them and acknowledge them so what I
guess maybe maybe I would I would say is
are they your desires or are they desire
someone else handed to you right right
well that's the whole thing I mean you
know many people especially in America
are buying things that if you probed him
why they're getting it it boils down to
I want to feel good for a couple of
hours yeah I want to spend money I don't
have yeah to buy things I don't need to
impress people I don't even know yeah on
the other hand though it's perfectly
okay if you say to yourself you know
what I really want that yes get it let
me show you how to even dream bigger so
I think for this person what I'm willing
to bet is that they are playing
whack-a-mole with their money so they
wake up they start the month oh I'm
motivated I need to save some money I
really should do that and then by the
end they're scrolling Instagram they're
reading their emails with links to stuff
to buy and they buy this and they buy
that and they don't even really care
about it I would rather have them sit
down and say you know what what do I
love
stop dreaming small dream big I I want a
leather jacket I'm gonna make this up
maybe I could get a leather jacket from
Gap dream bigger maybe you can get an
even cooler leather jacket or something
you really love okay great what's it
gonna take to get that I'm gonna need to
save for X months and I'm gonna
discipline myself by automating the
money so I don't have to log in every
day and by that you're building this
muscle of discipline of automation and
at the end the payoff is you get that
thing you truly loved what a lot of
people might discover which I think
aligns a lot with the minimalist
philosophy is I didn't really even want
this leather jacket yes ultimately the
message of minimalism is you probably
don't want that and my message is maybe
you did and if you did awesome now you
know the work that it takes to get there
and now you can plan for something even
bigger next time and my pit the answer
here really echoes what you were saying
is a bad habit is better replaced than
avoided so will you talk about what the
whack-a-mole this person niall
chronicles is saying well you know I've
got I want to buy this one I buy this on
to buy this and I think they're all bad
habits
well maybe most of them are but maybe
there is something that will truly add
value to your life that's the thing you
aspire toward and the other things are
then replaced by that higher-quality
thing totally agree
let's take dieting as an example by the
way dieting very interesting when I
first wrote this book ten years ago I
compared fitness and food with finances
and you know it's there's obvious links
you we don't count calories we don't
count where we spend our money etc etc
this time 10 years later I was strongly
advised to strip out all recommendations
about diets and food why because it's
become controversial
to even suggest that people might want
to change their body lose weight etc and
I refused because I've gone on not only
my financial journey but my fitness
journey I used to be 127 pounds super
skinny I called myself a skinny Indian
guy which is the language we use to
describe ourself is very toxic right we
some of us say oh I could never make
money my family doesn't do that on and
on and on I had to learn to change the
way I describe myself and then get help
from teachers and trainers and things
like that so in the book I talked about
again the similarities between fitness
and finances and one of the things
you'll see people when they're going
with their plate they're fixated on how
many carbs should I have pastas really
bad for you that's one way to look at it
let me try to take away the bad another
way to look at is let me start with the
good let me add a little bit more lean
protein it's okay if I want to have
dessert no problem but I'm gonna start
by filling my plate up with what's good
and that is totally applicable to
finances if this guy is worried about
all these bad quote bad things I don't
even like using the word bad these
things that he tends to overspend on
maybe he can start by saying what is the
thing I love let me focus on that and
the natural overspending areas will
disappear when he's focusing on what his
rich life is yeah I often think about
we're fixated on all of the negative
you're probably gonna get a negative
result there we've got another question
here from our lightning round Li Sophia
from Washington State asks how did I get
into this mess with all my credit cards
I just give you a pithy answer here a
ditch is dug one shovelful at a time I
mean that's ultimately you probably
didn't go out and get ten credit cards
here the what is it the average American
has four credit cards one in ten
American has ten or more active credit
cards in his or her wallet and you
probably didn't go out overnight and
have ten credit cards I'm gonna max them
out tomorrow
it happened one shovelful at a time
that's how you got to a ditch I'll give
you a second pit the answer here every
foundation was once a ditch and so you
might be in the ditch right now but this
could be your future foundation you
might be at your breaking point love
that mine is the problem is not credit
cards the problem and the solution is
you the credit cards if it wasn't the
credit cards it would have been
something else
the real opportunity here is to look at
why you opened him up go back and get
really specific what happened on that
sixth credit card somebody came to you
when you were shopping at Banana
Republic and said 10% off ho-ho 10% is
such a great deal you save four dollars
opening that credit card why are you
bothering most people are asking
themselves three dollar questions they
really should be asking themselves
30,000 dollar questions that's the real
problem I almost guarantee this guy's
going around trying to save four dollars
or oh I got a 10,000 mile bonus for
opening up this airline card stop
thinking at the three dollar level close
those accounts it'll hurt your credit
for a little while but they will recover
focus on one or two great credit cards
cash back travel keep it simple and
focus on changing your psychology away
from $3 questions to focusing on $30,000
questions like investing I think I would
say about credit cards what will wrap it
up on this is if you're in debt you
don't need credit cards I mean it and
then we could obviously have an argument
of whether or not they're beneficial if
you're out of debt we can have different
opinions on that but if you're gonna if
you're gonna if you want to get out that
ditch stop digging and and the first way
to do this I mean you gotta you gotta
get rid of these credit cards got to get
them under control I know for me I had
massive amounts of debt made really good
money but spent even better money and so
I had six figures worth of debt and I
had 14 active credit cards and the car
payments and the mortgage on the
oversized house with more toilets than
people liked it just I had all this
stuff that wasn't bringing me joy
satisfaction a sense of meaning to my
life you know can I tell you something
like when you say that and I
here you and I can just see it in your
face like it looks like hell to me to
just have all this stuff around and I
want to just contrast the name of the
book I will teach you to be rich with
this idea as you said of opulence my
rich life I've lived in the same
apartment for 10 years it's a
one-bedroom apartment I love it it's
very nice but my net worth has increased
over the last decade and I stayed I
picked the best and I stayed there I
picked the best computer and I kept it
on the other hand so that's not
important to me
I actually was driving around La and I
saw these massive houses and I didn't
feel like I want that not at all
I felt like oh my god that's a lot of
maintenance who's gonna clean the dust
off that's I don't want it yeah but also
you can appreciate it
and that's what I like about your
perspective is it it's just like if you
go to the Lachman you see a Picasso
painting you can enjoy it without having
to consume it right
yes and that that is really when you
start to understand your own desires and
acknowledge them it's like I appreciate
the beauty and the art and the craft but
that's not for me on the other hand
there are things that I absolutely love
and I save or invest to be able to enjoy
them and some of them are physical
material goods some of them are like you
said experiences so I just I want
everyone to be unapologetic about what
they love but also know that just cuz
your net worth increases you don't have
to buy another car landrover a new
apartment new computer you can keep that
stuff as it is you can focus like a
laser on the stuff you want listen we
got several more surprise questions here
what are your opinions using about using
credit cards to accrue points what
investment recommendations do you have
for those seeking early retirement we
could talk about that if a house payment
is the same as a rent payment could that
be considered good debt to take on if
I'm actually might disagree on that one
that'll be fascinating if I'm going to
college is that why is here wiser to
continue investing in my retirement
accounts or invest instead in my
education and minimize my school loans
and finally how should I prepare
financially to leave an unsatisfying job
that provides a comfortable living
to instead pursue a more satisfying
career and if you want to hear all that
you can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week we record an entirely different
much longer maximal episode on the
minimalists private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about stuff we don't usually talk about
in public
Plus patreon is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app you also
get access to our entire back catalogue
of more than 100 private podcast
episodes find all the details and all
the good stuff including an additional
private podcast episode every week over
at the minimalists dot-com slash support
and now here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi I'm Kari
from Denver with a tip about answering
the what do you do question I love your
advice about answering that question by
saying what I'm passionate about but I
found that my answers were being
dismissed a little bit maybe because I'm
a stay-at-home mom and there's a little
bit of like an entitled stigma attached
to that role so I tweet to my response
now I answer with I work really hard at
maximizing the things that matter most
to our family I'm an ambassador of
purposeful living so to speak and then I
go on to talk about writing and camping
and the other things that I'm passionate
about and ask the other person what they
are passionate about it's opened up some
really incredible conversations and I'm
so grateful for your advice hi my name
is Tracey Willard's and I live in Sioux
Falls South Dakota I have a comment is
listening in to your Vermont show and
somebody asked about children and how to
be a minimalist with all the stuff that
comes with that and I wanted to share a
couple of tips I have a one-year-old and
we started our minimalism during when I
was seven months pregnant before she was
born a couple tips I have learned over
the last year or so is our Father
Fergus asked for passes or memberships
to local museum
use gymnastic centers etc these get you
in your child out of the house and
engage you in your community
there's also extra perks discounts for
special events or numbers that I come
with those passes and it's a really
great way to do it
another thing is oftentimes children
under two are free for us so really your
membership only includes you maybe your
other family members or Plus Ones as far
as toys go rental services exists in
many places our local library for
example allows has a toileting service
so you can rotate toys out and take them
back without cluttering up your space
there are also online subscription
services that a better similar one local
one for us is called Bloom box and it
has really beautiful toys and
educational activities that go along
with them that you rent for a month
concern back
another thing about toys is that I found
is designating a space in your home to
keep those toys so that they're not
ending up everywhere around the house
really helps you to kind of keep me a
manage what you actually have and once
that space fills up you can get rid of
those toys or let go of toys toys can
also be donated if they're in good
condition to daycare centers children's
hospitals shelters etc you can also sell
them at stores like Once Upon a child as
far as clothes I've found going for
second hand is very helpful as many of
the clothes get ruined or messy anyway
often also the child grows out of
clothes before they're able to wear them
very much so it's nice to not have spent
a ton on it and no matter what baby
clothes are pretty much cute perfect
really cute thread up is another great
website that I've used to buy things
that are in great condition as well as
one's kind of child and then finally
with accessories try a packing party
with your bottles your towels your bibs
anything that isn't like the toys and
everything and if you don't use those
things in 21 days you probably don't
need them alright y'all thanks again to
ramita day make sure you check out his
book I will teach you to be rich
you can also find him online IWT comm is
his website and real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
if you like coffee
well if you like good coffee you know
Ryan and I own a coffee shop down in st.
Petersburg Florida or at least we're
partners in a coffee shop with Joshua
and Sarah Weaver our friends down there
and until recently the only place you
could get our coffee was in the four
walls of the coffee shop and now it's
available online and each month we're
doing something called the minimalist
choice it's our favorite coffee that
we're roasting and drinking right now
from bandit so if you want to find that
you just go to the minimalists dot
coffee
the minimalist stock coffee you can find
the minimalist choice our favorite
coffee of this month if you want to
check out our coffee and see what we are
drinking also if you want to check out
our favorite coffee houses throughout
the United States and worldwide we just
put a list and it's a growing list as
well you can find that at the
minimalists com we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well it's called
the minimalist favorite coffee alright
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
voicemail 4 zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists and if you want
our show notes in your inbox then sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm and you'll also receive
our simple Sunday emails each week for
added value this week let's listen to
our pal Matt carnies new old song this
year is the 10th anniversary of Matt's
second album city of black and white
it's my favorite of his six albums and
he's currently bringing new life to
songs from that collection by by
stripping them down to their beautiful
bones when I reached out to him he told
me that he quote went minimal with this
project here is the revisited reprise
and reassembled stripped down title
track form at Carney's city of black and
white and if you leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus